[Music]
now imagine a theoretical line
which has been recommended in many books
and videos
and as per the database
there are more than 500 plus feed a
games as well as
950 plus leeches games
goes into that direction
where white supposed to get an advantage
but the matter of fact is
with the help of modern chess engine
black can deliver a nasty punch
where almost
he is getting a winning advantage
isn't that amazing
well that's the case here because in
today's video
we are going to look at one of the most
amazing counter trick
in the varus attack from the black
prospector
after d4 it doesn't matter whether you
are knight to f6 or d5 player
let's say here black plays d5 first
and after knight to c3
black indeed goes for knight to f6
okay we have the verso attack on the
table
with bishop to g5
and the idea is very obvious
what white wants to do is he wants to
capture this knight and then
hit back in the center with e4
of course black shouldn't allow this and
accordingly
bishop to f5 is fitting reply
stopping e4
now if white capture this knight then
it doesn't matter much
black can capture with either of the
pawn and in both the case
we obtain the bishop pair
so nope that's not the right idea and as
per the database by far the most popular
choice is f3 again
same concept
take this knight and then look forward
for the move e4
okay black has to stop it once again
and he does by playing
knight b to d7
well we have reached to the most
critical position of this line
where as per any database if you look at
the most popular choice here is
knight captures d5 which looks more
natural in this position
not only destroying the whole black
center
but the big point is
after knight captures d5
white is regaining his piece back with
e4
and this is what i'm talking about
this has been suggested in almost all
theoretical manuals
and yes indeed
so far white was scoring better
until the morning chess engine
enters
into the room and dismissed the whole
line
so before i move on guys i like you to
find a killer move here
which actually refute the whole white
concept
did you find it
i hope you indeed see this nice cute
move
at six
and sometimes chess is an amazing game
as the small moves can create wonders
well black is attacking the white bishop
and accordingly white has two major
choices
and amongst them the first move bishop
to d2 which is the second most popular
choice
i'm afraid is a bad one because
now black has a very nice reply
namely
e5
so it is very obvious that if white
tried to capture his piece back
then after e captures d4
white gets some horrible pawn structure
on the king's side
which is really undesirable
so many white players think that okay
those two pieces are not going anywhere
i am going to take on e5 first
and although
as per the engine knight captures e5 is
black's best response
after this i am going to recommend a
straightforward move which wins on the
spot
congratulations if you see the move
bishop captures e4
bam
and after this white is almost dragged
into the force variation
now if white doesn't capture this piece
then black is a clear piece up
so let's see what happens after app
captures e4
yup you guessed it queen to h4 check
g3
and after queen captures e4
white has choices
if you block the check with either
bishop or the knight
then we are more than happy to take this
rook
but remember if you block the check with
the queen
then i do not recommend to capture the
rook in the corner as after knight to f3
black has some serious problem taking
out his queen
i have lost a bad game against a feed a
master like this
so instead of this i recommend the
straightforward approach
you exchange the queen
and after bishop takes e2 you just
gobble up the e5 pawn
where the end result is
not only black has some superior knight
sitting in the center of the table
but
we are clear pawn up and if we play
accurately from here
i am definitely sure
black can obtain the full point
so this is the big time problem if your
opponent continue with bishop to d2
okay
by far the most popular choice is bishop
to h4
keeping that e pawn in lock and key
but amazingly enough
here the modern chess engine
come up with the move which is very
difficult to find out by a human
first thing first if you look at the
bishop to h4 it has now given the access
to this juicy square e3
but there is a saying that a lone
soldier cannot do anything
so this knight needs some support
and you will be surprised to see black's
next move
look at this guy
knight to b6
what a move
and now
white has few choices
including capture either of the pieces
and
the best choice c3
but amongst all of them
black get a great advantage
let's start with the most obvious one he
captures f5
by far the most popular choice
but i think after this white is losing
yup you heard it right white is losing
with the following sequence
knight to e3
attacking the queen
it doesn't matter wherever the queen
goes let's say queen to d3
we have this nasty move
queen captures d4
and after this no matter how well white
riggers
he cannot save the game
well obviously enough if you take the
queen then after knight to c to check
not only black is regaining the queen
back
but at the end result is
we are clear pawn up and there is
already ongoing pressure on the f5 bomb
so obviously queen captures d4 is a bad
idea
the more accurate choice here is bishop
to f2
but even after this white is not out of
the trouble
here we can go again with this forcing
sequence
queen captures d3
white is forced to capture with the
bishop in order to protect the fork on
c2
and after this
yup your guess is equal as mine
you take the g2 with the check
and after king to f1 and the moon knight
to f4
once again we have the scenario where we
are clear porno
but this is even better because white
has now
completely fractured pawn on the king's
side
with all together gives black a huge
advantage
okay
let's check out the second alternative
what happens if white take the night
well after this
i recommend this straightforward
approach
you take on d5 with the queen
and no matter whatever white plays let's
say bishop to d3 or c3
are most popular choices
after this
we wants to castle on the queen side
and as i have highlighted over here
the simple but effective plan of
campaign is
you play g5 and then play the move e5
which put tremendous pressure on this d
pawn
and in most of the lines
we are going to munch this d pawn
let me show you how we can achieve it by
showing my one of the recent game
against a 2300
leeches rated player
here he continued with bishop to d3
i simply exchanged the bishop
and then as mentioned earlier
first
g5
and after bishop to g3
obvious moon e5
the d-pawn is pin so you cannot take on
e5
if you take with the bishop then after
queen takes
white is losing a piece
so my opponent come out with a strong
move
queen to f5 check
and after my sneaky rook to d7
why to his horror find out that
he has some huge problems
for example
if we continue with d captures e5
then queen to d2 more or less finish the
word
so that's not a good choice
if you take back with the queen then
this is even worse
as after rook to e7
white loses the queen
and apart from it white doesn't have any
good choices
for example in the game my opponent
choose the move bishop to e5
which is turn out as a big time disaster
as after the move f6 i think by force
black is winning
the bishop is pin
so white has to take with the queen
but then there comes this forcing
sequence
bishop to g7
queen to f5
rook 28 once again threatening the queen
so my opponent wisely play knight to e2
but after bishop takes pawn takes
rook to e5
white played queen to c2 and then
resigned the game
as he can clearly see black's next move
yup
rook to e7
and the white knight is a complete
corner
last but not least engine's best choice
here is
knight to e2
but once again we can create the
pressure on the d pawn by playing bishop
to g7
and kindly note that white cannot castle
here as the a2 pawn draw and
engine's best choice here is castle on
the king side
after that we have this nice sequence
which is in fact never played in any
game but it's worth to remember
pawn takes d4
white has to exchange the queen now
and after knight to d4
i recommend this nice sequence
knight to e3
attacking the
rook cannot go to even as there is a
knight to c24 coming up
so white is forced to play rook to f2
but after bishop takes knight pawn takes
you cannot take immediately due to
bishop to e5
but black has this nice intermediate
sequence
knight to f5 attacking the bishop
bishop to e5 and now very nice move
rook to
where the amazing part is
white would love to defend the d4 pawn
but he cannot because if either of the
rook comes on the e file
then the e5 bishop will drop
the best what can do is forget about the
spawn and play something like h3
but after knight to d4
we have the same scenario
black is a pawn up and with some
accurate play this is definitely a good
advantage for the black camp
last but not least engine's top choice
here is c3
but
i don't think so this can create any
problem for you
as white is forced to enter our
comfortable territory
by playing the move
bishop to h7
well now white has to capture the piece
back
and after this if you have paid
attention to my previous line
this is pretty much similar
yup you captured on d5
and followed up with this very obvious
sequence
castle on queenside play g5 and then
play e5
where the end result is you get this
tremendous pressure on the d-pawn and in
most of the line black do get the pawn
advantage
that's it guys i hope with this mini
lecture
now you are confident enough
to play this line in the tournament
practice
remember
when you open and continue with this
theoretical move knight captures d5
you give him this rude shock
with this very cute little move at six
and after this
no matter however white plays
black is getting
at least an advantages position
just within the opening stage
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care